sack zu sagen hier ist er heute plus
live stream mit einem etwas anderen live
stream als sonst denn unsere
gesprächspartner denen wir gleich hier
haben der hat keine steile these der hat
einfach nur recht wenig geschlafen die
letzten 70 stunden und zwar schalten wir
gleich in den weltrekordversuch von den
kollegen von das schaffst du nie wer die
nicht kennt ich schreib mal kurz hier
auf unseren rechner
und so sieht deren kanal aus und die
machen so lustige sachen wie zum
beispiel über die alpen mit dem scooter
oder einer kochen im vulkan und sie
haben sich jetzt vorgenommen sie brechen
den 72 stunden talkshow weltrekord was
das soll das frage ich jetzt mag der ist
mir live zugeschaltet immer münchen
bekommen wir dass unsere applaus sehr
schön so marc du musst du musst mal
allen die das jetzt nicht mitbekommen
haben was hier eigentlich macht in zehn
sekunden erklären was zur hölle hier
eigentlich versucht warum bis 72 stunden
ist 70 stunden minutenlang aufgestellt
und serien und das mussten sie stellten
hier überbieten
jetzt kann man sich natürlich fragen
warum ausgerechnet talkshow talk show
ist ja eigentlich ein genre aus dem
alten fernsehen das machen wir ja hier
auf youtube nicht läuft es trotzdem
ja das liegt an der bildungswoche die
umzüge sender haben die ard und zwar die
aufgabe war jede stunde jede stunde ein
stückchen schlauer zu werden
und tatsächlich habe ich gäste
eingeladen denen was bald bringen
konnten aus ganz verschiedenen spektren
herr lesch war da ein physiker aber auch
breakdance h oder ein core gebracht hat
so war jede stimme und fragt ist hier
irgendjemand anderem studie
wer ist jetzt gerade im hintergrund die
schlechte nachricht ist sie haben den
rekord gebrochen sie haben es
tatsächlich geschafft 70 stunden und
fünf minuten zu überbieten
ich hab verloren dh du bist auch 70
stunden woche wahrscheinlich ne da
darfst du zwischendurch nach hause gehen
ich habe den besten job wieder durch von
allem ich hab hier gilt das dann auch in
hitlers dann noch ne ne ben standorte
sie ja gar nicht was befürchtet was du
fühlst du denn jetzt also die geben wir
auch immer strafen auf wirst du die
nächsten 72 stunden wach bleiben müssen
und dabei fauligen fisch essen
ich würd ich wollte wissen ob du jetzt
schon weiß was auf dich zukommt und
[Musik]
hafeneinrichtungen
das heißt da mal was vernünftiges in
deinem leben
da macht noch was wichtiges damals noch
was von dem krieg ist in deinem leben
hast du denn das gefühl dass tatsächlich
dieses talkshows onkel wasser ja ein
ganzes stück bogen habe dass das auch
auf youtube eine chance hat eine zukunft
[Musik]
was war denn das was du jetzt gelernt
dass bei der ganzen geschichte sind eure
eine themenwoche vorgehen das man jetzt
ist unser beitrag dazu zu eurer ard
themenwoche lernen macht keine schalten
wäre eine band spielt ganz wichtiges
thema security bei einer schalte dabei
zu haben und die spanier hinter direkt
zu halten
ich glaube auf gar keinen fall ich habe
ihr schon so viel schlafmangel durch
unseren acht sendungen von daher kann
ich sehr gut nachfühlen wie es euch geht
ich möchte diesen weltrekord nicht
versuchen zu knacken den den schenke ich
euch den keller behalten
tage unterhalb würden aber in diesem
sinne vielen dank ich mitnehmen und
fürst hinter die kulissen zeigen
jetzt müsste man mal kurz den zentren
oder ist das jetzt auch verboten bald
eigentlich wollten wir euch auch mit in
set reinnehmen aber das ging nicht hat
mag erklären weil du dann den weltkrieg
unterbrochen nettes kannst du jetzt
laufen oder geht es nicht ich kann
leider nicht aber ich darf nur hier
bauen lassen sich von dem bett bauer ich
nachts geschlossen
die punkte sind meine küche gekocht
haben was ich jetzt mal gerne wissen
würde lieber mag
wie riecht das in einer fernseh studio
wenn dort in den letzten 72 oder 70
stunden die ganze zeit gesendet wurde
inklusive der ganzen mitarbeiter
dahinten ich glaube die luzerner nicht
macht hat sich öfter umgezogen als
helene fischer auf ihren konzerten
ich glaube da war zeit für eine kleine
katzenwäsche immer zwischendurch hätte
nicht dahinter eine dusche oder wie habt
ihr das gemacht wie ist beim fernsehen
so üblich ist da ist ein kleiner bottich
mit ein bisschen lauwarmem wasser so wie
du das auch ausländer macht gekämpft und
dann wird sich gleich mal kurz feucht
durch gewesen das haben sie bei uns
schon gestrichen wegen zu viel gebühren
kostet soviel geld lieber mag ich
wünsche euch noch ganz viel spaß ich bin
sehr gespannt auf deine sozialstunden
was du da alles verrichten wirst und bin
vor allem sehr gespannt wie das in den
nächsten lassen wie das dann weitergeht
wenn ihr mit den 72 stunden durch seit
ich glaube dann kann man erst mal nicht
mehr schlafen
kurz in diesem sinne wünsche ich euch
viel spaß stelle krise nach münchen aus
mainz und das war's ich sag auch an
dieser stelle ich bin gespannt ob nicht
doch noch jemand einschläft in der
nächsten stunde aber es sieht ganz gut
aus sind genug leute da die sie davon
abhalten können in diesem sinne erstmal
euch ein schönes wochenende wir sehen
uns nächste woche wieder mit einem
livestream weltrekordversuch aber mit
steilen thesen und spannenden
gesprächspartnern in diesem sinne
macht's gut